All right, we're back with the incredible,
my favorite, Ilana Glazer.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Well, in honor of your motherhood...
if it's okay, I'd love to do the Final Five with you,
but we could make it mom-edition.
I love it.
(audience clapping)
All right,
it's the Final Five: mom-edition.
(drums rolling)
(Ilana laughing)
(Drew coughing)
(cymbals crash)
I'm losing my voice.
You're slaying, Drew, you're killing it.
Okay, I'm gonna ask you five questions about being a mom
and you need to answer honestly.
(Ilana sighing)
Okay,
babies have distinct cries,
can you give us your best hungry cry for an infant?
Mm
It's like, I guess a cry is like, (crying)
but she's like, (loudly whining).
Yeah, there you go.
(audience laughing)
It's high, it's a thin-tone.
(Drew sighing)
It was so great when the pediatrician,
'cause I would call him all the time like so hypochondriacal
and he was like, "You'll know the cry
that makes you call me for real."
Love it.
And I was like,
"Ooh, okay, thank you Dr. Waldstein."
Did your feet get bigger?
(audience members laughing)
No.
All the weight (laughing) and water
and growth happened in my chest area.
(audience laughing)
So interesting.
I grew three shoe sizes.
Three?!
Three,
I went from a six to a nine.
(Ilana laughing)
It was inversed.
That's wild.
Wild.
And then my whole
shoe collection, I donated
Damn.
I mean, that's an investment, you know?
Yeah, I was really bummed.
Oof.
I was trying to be Carrie Bradshaw and I ended up...
Damn.
more like Dr. Scholl's.
(Ilana and audience laughing)
Okay.
What is one item from your babied registry
that you cannot live without?
You know what?
An amazing standup comedian, Yamaneika Saunders,
New York through-and-through,
got us this mobile from Nordstrom; pink.
I really didn't want like-
it's just like nice to look at
and it was like a little forest of rattles;
a mushroom rattle, a little snail rattle and it really...
for six months it was just so entertaining to my baby.
A mobile from Nordstrom.
(Ilana and audience laughing)
Gulp.
Love it.
It sounds really happy, I want one.
Yeah. (laughing)
If you have adult things laying around,
what age do you think,
"Meh, we'll just start hiding that."
(Ilana sighing)
(Ilana laughing)
I guess so they're like-
right now I'm thinking of the kitchen,
like these things are on the counter.
I would say at age...
three, between two and three
it's time to get the lock boxes.
I'm so mad, because I have one for you
and it's just not here yet.
Oh.
But I bought you a lock box.
I'll wait.
I can't believe you said it.
I'll wait, I'll wait.
And here's the best part about this lock box;
it's a code, so you don't have to lose the key
and do that whole thing.
Love it, love it.
What's your biggest mom fail?
You know what I have to stop doing
is I'm Q-tipping the boogers out of her nose
(audience laughing)
and it's kind of compulsive
and I just need to stop and let them come out as they come.
(audience laughing)
Have you ever had to do the NoseFrida?
(audience member clapping)
I have it on hand.
Yes! Love it. (clapping)
I don't know what was wrong with me,
I was sucking my kid's snot out like it was-
I mean, that's love.
Yeah.
If you don't know what this is
it's basically a booger straw
Yeah.
for you and your baby.
And you (slurping)
Yes, some nods.
'Cause sometimes it's stuck and they can't breathe!
(audience laughing)
And when they can't breathe, they can't sleep,
so believe me, you start sucking.
(audience laughing)
That's right.
(Ilana laughing)
(audience clapping)
Ilana Glazer,
I have waited for so long to meet you,
to have this moment with you;
my daughter and I are your biggest fans, you and Abbi,
we are always cheering you on both individually and together
and it is just such an honor
to finally make your acquaintance.
I'm honored, I am honored, you are so generous to me.
All right, the new episodes of "The Afterparty"
are available Fridays on Apple TV+ and just...
Oh my gosh.
(audience cheering)
Finally!
(bright music)